what's up y'all it's your girl Queen
niga make sure you guys check me out on
the bootle Kev
podcast bootle Kev podcast bootle Kev
show special guest in here Queen niga
welcome Hi how are you welcome the way
you said my name was funny you said
Queen niga welcome thank you thank for
um congrats you got the new EP out yes
thank you uh it's called after the
butterflies now what does that mean does
that mean like once things get a little
toxic in a relationship cuz then there's
the butterfly stage I always say you get
into a relationship things are beautiful
and then you know what happens when the
butterflies go away I wouldn't call it
toxic I don't think it's toxic sometimes
just becomes like you know I mean real
and realistic like realistically people
are not going to be like in love well
super duper in love every single day
forever like of course that happens like
in the beginning where you see the kind
of girl I am like I see no wrong in the
beginning like you can't do no wrong the
honeymoon stage yes basically after the
honeymoon stage um and when the
rosecolor glasses come off and it's like
okay yeah there's things I actually
don't like about you and like things
that he don't like about me and and
disagreements and like possibility of a
breakup you know like no yeah like once
you first start dating somebody you'll
put all of the like if you're really
into somebody you all the stuff that
everything iside you just put to the
side I even love the flaws like I love
this like in the beginning I love the
things that I shouldn't so let me ask
you this cuz I feel like it's unfair of
women to like love something about
somebody or even even men too cuz this
happens a lot like I have friends of
mine
who like my wife used to be a dancer so
I I didn't never gave a [__] still don't
give a [__] but I have homies of mine
who like like you'll fall like you'll
fall for somebody be like and fall for
them in a certain line of work or for
who they are at a certain time and then
hold that against them later mhm have
you ever done that are you guilty of
that no um wait hold on I maybe I spoke
too quick like you like some of the
flaws like you embrac the flaws
initially but eventually you're like man
I don't like you cuz this what it's like
well you like you knew that you knew
what it was when you got something that
you have yes something that you like
went into knowing it was there you
didn't mind it and then all of a sudden
like all of a sudden it's a thing yeah
um H I don't know why my voice is crack
like that but
um what could I say maybe a sometimes
girls I won't say like this is like
specifically
to me but sometimes girls love
that that little like telling you what
to do kind of thing when a guy's like no
you ain't don't wear this or don't do
that and like it's like oh it's so cute
like he don't want me to he cares but
yeah like or he's you know it's cute
he's a little but then after a while
uming it becomes controlling and it
becomes like okay annoying like you're
not my dad yeah um I do believe you
should have a certain respect though for
the man that you're with as he should
have for you but of course I think
that's like a big sign of like
insecurity though for for a male yeah
what to kind of tell you not to wear
yeah or like that or I also feel like I
feel like dudes like will have a a real
like inclination to like try to keep
women
like in yeah or in their little like
grasp you know what I'm saying as as
opposed to like like you know I feel
like a lot of guys don't want to lose
they want to keep the girl their girl to
themselves yeah and it's like hey man
like I mean if you really locked in with
that girl you ain't going to lose her
that's what I'm saying I remember I
wasn't able to wear uh a bathing suit in
my last relationship um a bathing suit
Yeah well yeah I had to like put shorts
over my even if it was a one piece I
couldn't do it I couldn't wear a bathing
suit oh my God yeah so like um and it
was just I don't know it was it was
weird but um and like we're like so I
grew up in a church we were both
Christian but he said he appreciated how
like Muslims
you know how the wives were always
covered and like red flag um and I you
know to me it was just like that that
was really weird I did not like that at
all the my current relationship he like
don't tell me anything about what well
this is the thing like it's a bathing
suit like you can't help the way you
look in a bathing suit like my booty I
didn't even have a BBL then like my my
booty was like it was a regular booty
right so I don't even understand why but
like that's [__] crazy it's a regular
butt damn so like is that was that kind
of like a a reason for you to like okay
I I gotta get out of this thing oh no it
was way more things than that like that
was just you know but I don't even want
to like hone in all that I just thought
since we were talking about yeah yeah no
that's wild though yeah dude's got to
stop being that way man especially if
you got a beautiful woman it's like hey
man it doesn't matter if you're a mom it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter like a
woman should be able to like wear what
she wants Kiki Palmer's baby daddy is
[__] he's a s that dude is tripping
bro I'm like you got mad cuz your girl
went out with her homies in Vegas she
had a Vegas outfit on she's a she just
had a baby this is a great night out for
her Usher happened to sing to her I just
don't think that it you know has to be
um a limit on I mean okay I will say
this like just we're all different
everyone's different right I I have worn
some things that were like revealing um
but not like super duper revealing like
where I'm just out here naked but like
that's to each his own yeah I mean also
you know it's uh you're an artist yeah I
mean what that mean I mean that like as
an artist like you're a beautiful woman
who I'm sure you know like a part of
your uh your brand is how you're also a
beautiful woman thank you yeah so yeah
shout out to your current guy who feels
like he's got it figured out huh thank
you I guess thanks on his behalf uh
anyway yo so um so once once you get
past the butterflies how do you make the
relationship work oh that's a good
question um I feel like um a lot of
people don't believe in this but therapy
therapy is really good um because it's
good to have like a non-biased couples
therapy couples therapy is great and the
individual therapy because I I do feel
like a lot of reasons why relationships
don't work out is because individually
like we haven't like healed our own
traumas so like something that the your
partner could do could trigger something
from like uh you didn't even know you
like yeah like make yeah and it's like a
root behind it like it could be nothing
even super huge about it but like
something really triggered something you
went through like I know I have triggers
and traumas from like just people
telling me what to do and people
controlling me and so like even if in
the past I've gotten mad like if he's
tried to give me
some advice and it maybe was like a
little it was just little too sometimes
the truth be hurting and it like
triggers something from the past yeah
yeah when really he was just trying to
look out for my best interest so I mean
that's just an example I feel like
therapy couples therapy regular therapy
and just like keeping it spicy I feel
like um when you stay in the house and
you're just especially if you live with
a person like if y'all are trapped in
four walls oh yeah and you just do the
same thing every day especially if you
got kids like y'all need to get out the
house and do new things like things that
y'all haven't done together even if it's
in the same city or go on vacation
whatever but like um make new memories
always cuz if you don't have nothing to
talk about everything just becomes like
super Bland no it's definitely hard
especially when you have kids and you're
always home the kids do a number I got
two kids so I me too so what you got
girls or boys two boys I got two boys
too yeah I my one of my kids just turned
18 so I have like a little man that
lives in my house L literally he could
go buy cigarettes right now oh wow how
old are your kids yeah um they're eight
and four um so you have like a
eight-year-old is like a little man too
kind of yeah he's about to be nine
February my he's grown youngest is about
to be five in January so yeah he he he
what's he into is he into like YouTubers
or yeah he wants to be that's what he
grew up on he's he wants to be a
streamer yep yeah CJ wants to be a
streamer he already has a PC he I have a
10year old that's like all that they're
into these YouTubers and these like
influencers watching the reaction Chan
beast and reaction channels and they be
on the reals or shorts the YouTube
shorts are crazy it's like I can't even
keep up like sometimes he'll be
scrolling through and I like here some
stuff I he should and I'm like turn that
off every day every single day my kid
he'll be sitting and having breakfast
and he throws on YouTube on the big TV
but he puts the shorts on and he'll just
hit next on all this and I'm like bro
they love the shorts it's crazy this is
this is the generation of children that
we both have it's scary we'll see what
they grow up to end up being yeah well
I'm I'm going keep praying over mine cuz
uh for sure so I do think therapy is
something that like there's obviously
you know a lot of people have um
starting to kind of break down down the
I guess the uh
negative uh stigma about it mhm what's
the negative stigma I I just think I
think I think you know in the last
decade or so like it's been a lot more
acceptable to like openly say hey I'm I
I'm going to therapy I think before you
would think that there was something
wrong with you you know but it's not
it's like sometimes you need to kind of
work through like stuff that's
subconsciously there that you don't even
know I feel like everyone in the whole
entire world needs therapy I agree it's
it doesn't mean you're crazy or you're
psychotic it's I feel like because
everyone in this whole world's life is
not perfect and everyone has been
through something even if your life was
like super good growing up there's
something there's like something that
you could maybe heal from or maybe not I
don't know maybe I could be wrong but
majority of us need something to heal
from so 100% have you ever uh done any
psychedelics U what's that like shrooms
or anything oh I don't do drugs oh okay
well I mean you know some people say
they're drugs some people say they're
not drugs they're healing yeah I don't
do drugs
I I have I have smoked weed um before um
and I really didn't have a good
experience with it yeah weeds weeds
whatever um I would never in my life do
an edible I see people go crazy yeah
don't ever eat weed oh never it's the
worst worst idea so the thing about
shrooms is like uh uh there's like it so
they just legalized them in Oregon last
year I think M so like uh veterans who
have PTSD M they go through psilocybin
therapy and it like it it really is like
I mean I'm sure that it could help some
people don't get me wrong it's a it's
it's going to be like a legal form of
therapy in the next like decade for sure
okay so drugs and therapy that's shrooms
shrooms no not not drugs like what what
are shrooms though is that like an
actual mushroom that grows from the
ground correct really yes the ones that
we eat uh no there's different types of
mushrooms obviously these are
psychoactive they have a ingredient
called psoc well I probably would go
insane I probably would probably die you
might you might but you might not um
that's crazy
well shout out to you I mean you I feel
like I'm always impressed when I see
someone with a beautiful voice also be a
pothead really oh I'm like you smoke a
lot to have to be able to sing like that
like yeah sometimes it helped the
raspiness of people voices true if you
got the raspy thing going I I get that
you've also kind of been like uh one of
the go-to like hook people I feel like
for a lot of rappers what has been like
your favorite hook you've cut that
wasn't for your own [__] for my own song
a hook um
um I think you know I I did one for
Jeezy it's um Jeezy Benny The Butcher um
the real Hood songs I just like I like
being the bringing the sugar to the
spice or however you would say it like I
like being the sweet voice that comes on
like a real rough neck kind of song um
it's easy to do it with melodic rappers
I I like to specifically do do hooks on
like the thug thug out something well
cuz yo like in the 2000s that was the
thing that was the thing yeah you would
have like a with an amazing dope female
singer or male singer and it would be
like a dope record like even back when
like I mean I love Tupac like I grew up
on Tupac my mom loved Tupac so like the
women that he would have on there like
just singing their heart out I feel like
if I was back in that era that would
have been me you would have been on the
Tupac was is Tupac like your goat my
goat yeah who your favorite I never
really said he was my goat um who's my I
mean he's he's definitely like a fave
like I I have a lot of faves that are
like OG's like like Whitney Houston
shout to Whitney yeah um but yeah I love
love love Tupac who's who do you think
uh I think Whitney's probably got the
best voice ever best voice ever um she
has a very like very powerful what her
one of the best voices Adele there too
um Kiki Wyatt um for sure her voice is
insane of course Beyonce's voice is
insane Beyonce is the goat but that's
like I mean everybody knew that Beyonce
is like the best performer um but
Whitney's
vocals I just feel like you put a like
we're in a room there's no mics you just
got a belt she probably just command the
whole room like yeah shout out to
Whitney what's your uh what's your
growing up what was like your favorite
top two or three R&B albums top two or
three R&B
albums
H do I have to say albums cuz sometimes
I would just pick songs from albums okay
give me those my top two growing up
um I listen to a lot of now this is only
up for my mom what she would listen to
like I listen to a lot of
um Monica Lauren
Hill um TLC s
SWV uh Ashanti and uh aarie aarie was
fire yeah I love I wanted to be here
when I was little shout out to Ashanti
she just re-recorded her her albums cuz
she didn't own her master so she did a
whole new version of her debut album so
if you're going to stream Shanti stream
the new version yeah go get that she
gets paid off for that yeah and see
that's a beautiful thing I I currently
own my masters so that's amazing yeah I
was that something that you got from the
jump or did you have to negotiate that
from the jump okay from from the
beginning of being sign that's important
yeah very important um because now you
don't have to resing your [__] 20 years
yeah cuz it don't it happened I mean
Taylor Swift just had to do it you know
yeah that's crazy I think maybe they had
to redo it because back then maybe it
was stricter things stricter policies
there was worse deals back then oh yeah
the record deals back then were
terrible they were the worst well shout
out to guys shout out to you you got the
uh you also had the leverage to ask for
your Masters because a lot of artists if
they're brand new they don't have like
you have I came I came in with leverage
when I was in signed because I already
had a fan base my yeah the YouTube going
yeah yeah I already have a fan base so
if no one else in the world listens to
me my my 5 million or whatever
percentage of them they're going to
listen to I was going to say coming in
as like a you like someone who had a
YouTube fan base you've done such a
great job of like people well first of
all you have people who know you from
that but you also have people who just
know the music but I feel like you've
kind of been the kind of sole example I
think ddg has done a solid job I'm the
female he's the male but I feel like you
did such a good job of like I don't even
think of you as like that like there's
been some YouTubers making music and the
music sucks and then they go back to
YouTube yeah but you're like to me
you're an artist first now like you're
so talented and music so high level I
like to say that I I'm not a YouTuber
that turned into an artist I've I've
always been an artist and just turned
into a YouTuber and now I'm doing what I
was suppos it just so happened that like
some people discovered you on you yeah
that was the I guess that was the thing
cuz you know I did American Idol um two
time well I'm just say one cuz the first
time I didn't even make the first round
but I did American Idol and I thought
that was my way when I was 18 I thought
that was going to be my way to you know
to make it to make it how far did you
get um I think top 40 and they booted me
they were booting groups they had to get
rid of people so I you know they were
tripping yeah I my dreams were really
crushed but I was young and so then from
then I was like I'm not going to really
do music anymore maybe this industry is
not for me maybe I should just do gospel
you know I grew up singing in church um
but then I started YouTube cuz like I
mean I had a I had got pregnant I had a
son it was broke and like YouTube was
you know it was there it was there for
people who don't know it's free to like
if you have a camera you have an iPhone
you could make a YouTube channel we were
doing it off of iPhone yeah and then
eventually when you get that first check
you get you a camera but like I I still
say like to this day um you know I left
YouTube for a little bit but I'm I'm
going back you are uh I'm I'm going back
well I used to do like pranks and and
Vlog daily Vlogs and things like that
but would you do you would do like the
fake couple pranks or I will say some of
them were playing cuz it's entertainment
like you know but um I won't do those
things anymore because I just feel like
that's cringey now oh because they're
obviously fake yeah I mean no no people
still watch a lot of but a lot of those
like shout out to my guy Mystic who was
one of those they're still fake they
they were so fake and I was just like
God how many times how many times can
you fake cheat on your girl before she
realizes it's not real yeah I mean
that's just like that's the but it
worked but I think that was that was an
era of YouTube yeah like everybody knew
like no one's getting a pencil stuck in
their eye like you know what I'm saying
but um what are you going to do now so
no I that's what I was getting to um so
I decided to go back and I don't know
why I called it a podcast cuz now it's
super being it's like being taken
serious or now I have a responsibility
to keep up but so I decided to take my
best friend her name is dami V who also
does music but um we be having
conversations on the phone and stuff so
I decided to just do do that as like a
chitchat girl but so it turned into a
podcast and it got a lot of views and
people already reached out like trying
to buy or put it on their platform list
don't sell it yet yeah yeah I I wasn't
going to do that no way what you should
do is do it once a week you got to be
consistent once a week yeah or or twice
a month at the very least so like I
literally this is my I only have my
second um my second one is coming out
tomorrow my second yeah so if you guys
can have like a consistent drop schedule
yeah whether it's twice I would I
wouldn't do anything less than twice a
month but if you could do once a week do
once a week but do it for like a year
and then you that'll be another seven
fig bag for you because I mean there's
other podcasts that are not as uh that
aren't very good that are yeah doing
doing good some money all right wait we
got to stop the interview this isn't
emergency my bookie just sent me an
email this week is Thanksgiving week and
we have an emergency offer sign up at
mybookie.ag we're going to have so much
football to bet on Thanksgiving how
about all the NBA that's going to be
happening on Black Friday oh football
weekend is going to be crazy and right
now this is very exclusive to the
bootleg C podcast they're doing a
110% deposit bonus that's that's right
this bonus offer is 110% deposit match
up to
$1,100 that means if you deposit $11,000
you will get
$1,100 for free put right into your
account to gamble with what are we doing
go to mybookie right now my bookie right
now sign up use the promo code bootleg
and this only is going on until November
26 that's Sunday all right so from now
till Sunday if you sign up in my bookie
you're going to get
110% deposit match uh bonus all right
that means you put in a th000 you're
going to get 11100 you put in 100 you're
going to get $110 did I do that right my
M's [__] all right but listen shout
out to mybookie all right sign up
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
this is so exclusive y'all this is only
happening this week so make sure you
sign up if you like to gamble like me
let's get this money baby all right also
want to give a shout out to our family
our new sponsor shout out to Munchies
man it's
Thanksgiving we love the munchies baby
all right want to give a shout out to
Munchies the market leader in the hemp
and cannabis space of course offering
you federally legal award-winning hemp
products that are comparable to your
favorite cannabis products all right and
it can get shipped straight to your door
and check this out the craziest sale of
the year so much going on so many
products I love the strawberry dream
gummies let's pop these boys open all
right this was dope the biggest sale of
the Year 40% off any order 40% off any
order of $60 or more right now if you go
to their website go to delt munchies.
comom use the promo code bootleg or
bootleg Kev you can use either one of
those bootleg bootleg C all together
you're going to get 40% off any order
this is what's dope about their gummies
all right their gummies are so good 100
Mig per gummy so you see all these
there's 1,000 Mig in the Box
they're vegan they're made with real
fruit and the flavors are crazy you've
seen the strawberry dream they also got
the apple berry nectar and this one
right here the tropical passion all
right and let's not forget that they
also got the Vapes for you yeah that's
right this is the grape R runs uh grape
jelly runs rather oh my God that
packaging looks good I'm about to also
they got the Strawberry Shortcake and
they got the pre-rolls the double doinks
man these ones right here are the Lemon
Cherry gelato that's a hybrid um and
look you can get 40% off right now 40%
off right now um all you have to do is
go to delt munchies. comom use that
promo code bootleg Kev or bootleg uh
you'll see it down below all right and
get 40% off of your order of $60 or more
now this is important because the sale
ends November 30th so head on over to
delt munchies. comom get you some of
that slushie juice these are very good
four gr blend of live resin thcp and
Delta 8 you can get a 5,000 hits out of
this bad boy plus free lanyard in every
bag delt munchies. bam yeah and then I
have the and then I have the leverage of
like bringing on artists because I you
can bring artists on and where you stay
at obviously I'm sure you're filming
there as well there's a lot of artists
that live there so you're going to be
able to have so many guests come in and
then you're probably also going to be
able to get like influencers you're
going to be able to also get like a side
of people who I don't think other
platforms are getting cuz I don't really
think like when I think of like drink
Champs artists go on there but usually
it's like old school hip-hop folks but
they're their guards down cuz they know
Nori but I feel like they artists and
influencers guards will be down with you
because they know you from the music and
you can have different conversations
with them yeah just realistic yeah do
that run that [__] up that' be dope yeah
that's the way to do you I didn't expect
for that to happen like I I kind of
thought that I was just going to do one
episode but at they were like waiting on
the next one I was like Oh shoot what
did I just do and I called it a podcast
so I feel like podcast is held to like a
high
no no no for sure well cuz now people
expect it to be a consistent thing well
if you caught a podcast now people oh
yeah I can't believe I did that to
myself but it's okay we going to keep we
going to keep it up I mean I need
another stream of income anyway so yeah
no you'll run it up for sure that's a
seven figure bag for you if you just
stay consistent that's easy for sure I
was going to say um for you like you've
always been somebody like how do you
deal
with um the negatives of being in the
public eye and being in a relationship
because I feel like I you've you've
that's got to be like a hard thing to
kind of like CU you want to keep your
private life private as much as you can
but you're also you you know what I'm
saying I'm also an artist and I got to
sing about what how I feel and things
like that um honestly I just tell what I
want to tell and whatever comes
out it comes out because it I don't know
like it just it it happens you can't but
even in that you don't respond like you
just you just deal with it in in your
household but um
I mean how do I deal with it I just like
oh I just answered it I just tell what I
want to tell yeah for sure um has there
been someone who you've met so far cuz I
always say in the music industry there's
tons of like uh people you know people
you work with uh Associates but not
necessarily friends has there been any
artists who you've bonded some real
friendships with since you've uh been
doing the music thing well well how
would you what would you call a friend
and what would you call an associate
well Associates like yo we work together
we hang we we a did the video you really
ain't seeing somebody or talking to them
outside of like the work like you know
but if there's somebody who you could
you know always call on for relationship
advice or or music advice or someone you
just chat with or like an actual friend
you know the the difference between a
work associate and a friend I don't have
an actual industry friend I don't but I
do have Associates like people that
would check on me from time to time um
you know and outside of music and stuff
and I appreciate it because I mean
sometimes you you can't be friends with
people um you cuz y'all don't have
enough time like I live in Atlanta most
of my peers live in LA so like we not
seeing each other on a daily basis or
but I do have those people that would
check on me I don't really have I can't
say I have friends though like that I'm
like this yeah they're like yo let's go
let's go get lunch just cuz cuz it's
Tuesday no more I have like more of a
actually yeah I barely have friends so
like in life you no you have a tight
Circle have very tight Circle as you
should yeah no that's fair
uh on the EP you got L Eric Bellinger
young boys on here um sh shout out to uh
uh L who's also amazing talent amazing
she's amazing talent she's one of the
ones that check on me she's super super
sweetheart yeah yeah have uh what's uh
what is that a studio session situation
or is that you send this the record off
tour type I send it to her because once
again I was in Atlanta and she's in La
so but we did tour together um for the
Mary J BL tour we both
you know I was there actually I went in
New in Brooklyn did you see did you see
did you see me in the red in the red fur
I was I was I I think I caught the tail
end of your thing me and Doc wner were
across the street having dinner and then
we came and you were on yeah oh that
yeah cuz yeah that's I forgot yeah that
was a crazy show the Brooklyn show at
Barclays yeah that man she brought
brought everybody out bro New York's
energy be crazy like I love New York yo
that's crazy in Rocking yeah no that was
a w again Mary J had like fabulous and
Puff Daddy and uh jiss and I feel like
Fat Joe I don't know it was like all in
New York a lot of people mhm what has uh
did like you and Mary developed any sort
of like she give you some game all you
guys want yes she definitely gave me
some game she gave me some game for sure
um I'm of course every every OG is going
to tell you to like keep going no matter
what but she definitely told me
like she told me to take my time and
like wait with marriage m um she been
through it yeah she's been through it I
mean I've been through it too though I
was already married before she told me
that so um but I am I feel like this
time around I am we have been taking our
time I mean we've been together for
almost six years now right and people
complain cuz you know I always I always
joke around like where my ring at you
know but um in reality I'm just like
whenever he I rather a man be like
ready like he better hurry up yeah no he
better hurry up but I'm saying though
like he better hurry up but I'm saying
that things should be handled before I
feel like um marital counseling is
really good like premarital counseling
before you yeah because like a lot of
times I do see like couples last a long
time outside of marriage and soon as
they get married it [__] things up they
get divorce and I'm a heavy believer in
marriage I still believe in marriage I
still believe it could work it's it all
depends on the two people and of course
keeping God like in your marriage you
know what I'm saying but um yeah it
ain't it ain't no
rush but it's not a rush for marriage
but it is like a little rush for like
the Ring The Ring cuz it's like okay at
least if you propose then we know where
we headed we've had conversations about
it like I know that he's going to but
it's like okay six years yeah but you
know sometimes men they want to get
certain things out the way like he wants
to put his clothing line and you know
like they want to
feel like they got a portion of their
life if you guys get married you making
him sign the prenup um is it going to be
the prenup H we haven't we spoke about
that you haven't signed that thing we
spoke about it um I don't know though I
don't I don't know but probably yeah for
sure I just feel like that it's only
fair that if we walk away from each
other it's only fair that we walk away
with what we came with you know what I'm
saying I agree 100% yeah but I feel like
I got the kind of relationship too that
like I don't think he would ever try to
you don't think no I don't think so I
hey you don't think I don't think so I
don't think he'll try to come for my
moneyy get the prep that's all I would
say I feel you like it's smart it is
very smart but I'm just saying the
person that I know no I I get it you
know what I'm saying like I get it but
um run that prenup bro a lot of women
don't think though and they do end up
you know but yo were you did you ever
when you were on tour with Mary J BL did
you ever see like how I always am
curious like when these like like she
wore like 11 outfits mhm how does that
work is there is there like a breakaway
pants on all these dresses and [__] like
way players have every tour I've done
like I just worn like one outfit I mean
well no i' on my birthday I feel like I
had a show where I changed once oh my
God you go behind stage and you just
like everybody is there like six people
just ripping [__] off of you yes wow
yeah I just saw I just saw scissor yeah
scissor scissor had like 11 outfits and
I was just like it was so fast the way
that's amazing that's amazing but like
um do cat had one outfit I I probably
would end up end up sticking with one
outfit or two if I have a break but I
don't I don't feel the I don't see the
need for all them outfits I just feel
like could be so frantic it is it's like
I don't see the need um what's your
favorite song on the EP on my
EP um I really like the first song
fading away and I really like the song
with me and Monica shout out to Monica
shout out to her she's a legend gona was
it you guys uh obviously she's someone
who you grew up listening to yes and
definitely a big deal to do a song a
full circle moment yeah like I a never
think I'd be doing no song with Monica
like yeah like when I was a kid it was
like Monica and Brandy that's like when
I thought I like R&B like chicks it was
Monica and Brandy mhm yep it was them
too and then and it's super dope cuz I
get to grow up and be a part of it and
they're still like around yeah have you
ever uh like H how how long do you want
to do
music that's a good question um I want
to do music cuz you know like sometimes
you'll see people like like you know uh
bry's a perfect example like we haven't
had Brandy like will like come and go
like every five or six seven years like
she kind of does it as she pleases now
that she's kind of like a OG is it
something like you want to okay so I
want to have like so I I dropped my very
first EP when I first came here it did
really well multiple platinum records
congrats double Platinum thank you um
and then like that was 2018 and then in
20202 years later I dropped my debut
album
misunderstood um which just went gold
congratulations that's a big deal especi
now yeah and so 3 years later I was
supposed to be dropping my my sophomore
album um but instead I dropped the EP
because like paperwork that be taking
too long like mm yeah you well you know
what it is these labels they're like
well if it's going to count as an album
yeah yeah so I the the the way I do it
the way I I on my contract I had to have
12 songs on an album if I already
dropped four songs and then I turn
around and drop a eight song EP my
contract is done I mean not my contract
but that portion of the contract
consider that a 12 song oh that's smart
cuz sometimes you you'll see these major
labels they they'll be like no this is a
mixtape so it doesn't count against your
deal it counts for me my next my next uh
album is going to consider my third
third third album again yeah yeah and I
have four so I would have one more left
with who I'm signed to but um Capital
right yeah Capital Records um dang what
was I going to say what' you ask me how
long I to do this music [__] what I was
going to say is I if I could just get a
super duper successful like album um
well you already got a gold one well
yeah I know but like I don't know like I
just feel like it's something more that
I'm trying to I don't know what it is
it's something more that I want but I
don't know what it is um I think once I
get more of a the a
general uh of a general public fan base
um then I will I'm also working on
releasing like launching a product too
um a like a line I don't know if it's I
don't know if I'm want to call it a
clothing line but just something really
comfy um if I'm really
if I have a really successful business
with that then I could take a break
because I don't have to depend on making
music for money just do it because you
want to shout out to the homies over at
Blue Chu man that's right blue Chu
everybody always ask me does blue Chu
work well you don't take my word for it
try it for free for a month by using
that promo code bootleg right now blueo
has the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Calis uh it's all wrapped up
into a blue chewable form delivered
right to your doorstep in discreet
packaging no doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with little erectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__]
let's be honest sometimes you need a
little extra you know a little extra
some some to get you over the Finish
Line get that blue cho baby bluechew try
the first month for free they're going
to give it to you for free a month
supply for free go to blue.com use the
promo code bootleg right now thank me
later let's get back to the interview
hey what up y'all we got to stop the
interview tell you about our good Folks
at King pom that's right let me tell you
about King pom man it's all we smoking
over here what I love about King pom
turpine infused flavor in each one of
these These are the margarita now this
is kind of the wave I've been on
recently these Margarita ones are
[__] fire no tobacco no nicotine
straight raw organic fresh leaves um and
what's dope is they got the tip you
squeeze the tip you hit one of these
boys and you just get hit with that
flavor man you get hit with that flavor
no matter how big or small the Palm is
you know what I'm saying this is what's
dope too uh King pal if y'all don't know
man there one of the leading Brands when
it comes to this real like organic smoke
light that's why I like them I like to
smoke clean nothing smokes cleaner than
a King Palm so if you're in your hood
you're in your neighborhood you're in
your [__] City your area
wherever you're at go to your local
liquor store they're going to have King
Pals all right so pick them up there you
can also go to 7-Eleven or this is what
I suggest you do right
now come on shout out to the king poms
man go to the website King pom.com
if you go to King pom.com you use the
promo code bootleg this is what we're
doing 50% off whatever you order they
got so much at King pom.com not only do
they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the gas
trays they got them all the cones
50% off all the smoking accessories all
the leaves you need all the flavors 50%
off King pom.com promo code bootleg also
speaking of [__] you're going to get
some money off of our family our dogs
are are listen I'm going to uh Tampa to
go DJ for these guys holiday party Odd
Socks baby the holidays are here now is
the time to go to oddsocks official.com
and use that promo code bootleg all
right use it right now and guess what
you're going to get 20% off at checkout
now the dope thing about odd Soxs they
got all the crazy licenses they just
locked down Coca-Cola recently yeah yeah
look at those they just locked down
Hasbro so they got Power Rangers
Transformers all that I mean look they
got cheit bro you know what I'm saying
they got Hershey's chocolate bro they
got WWE they got Breaking Bad they got
Top Ramen they got the draws they got
the socks they got the slippers they got
the Hat they got the belt whatever you
need oddsocks official.com load up for
the holidays gift odd Sox to your loved
ones whatever they're into there's an
odd Sox for it odd Sox official.com use
the promo code bootleg when you check
out save 20% off let's get back to the
interview yeah I'll do it cuz I I want
to do it well your podcast is going to
Boom if you do it if you really podcast
clo like podcast um product line so the
product line going to be like loung and
clothes like if I'm at home I want to
watch Netflix I can wear your your [__]
maybe go to the grocery store oh like
yeah but I of course want to make it cuz
I'm big on Comfort like I just love I'd
rather be comfortable than cute anytime
for sure for real like I can't I usually
can't wait to get home wipe off my
makeup take off my heels time yeah and I
like and I'll go out I'll make a public
run or like I don't understand these
guys who like go eat food with like
these like terrible designer outfit
on and he like dude why be stressed the
whole time cuzz what if like what if
like you take a bite of your steak and
like juice hits your [__] $3,000 ugly
ass I just want to be com t-shirt like
you know like some people just you know
are like they just love fashion and they
that's their passion I don't think I the
guys I'm talking about they let the
designer wear them they don't wear the
designer okay there's two ways you could
you could let the designer wear you
which a lot of you [__] scammers are
doing out there m a lot of these guys
who are like 75 lbs over the maximum
size that the shirt is made in Lord have
mercy [__] gut hanging out Jesus uh
and then you know you could do the
subtle designer you know I love subtle
things I'm such a dainty girl yeah I
know I got this one but you know I had
to wear because I'm but that's even
that's even like a subtle chain it's not
like some crazy you ain't got like your
[__] Queen [__] my man had to force me
to wear this and another chain that he
bought me I'm really I don't in my
stylist they're like put on the Cuban
I'm like I just want to wear like a
little dainty gold chain with a V Clea
yeah like maybe something cute but um
yeah I'm a dainty girl okay well look
the EP is out right now everybody can go
support it after the butterflies yes
after the butterflies and I'm going to
say this like if you really really
really support me it's one thing to
stream and I love streams no [__]
streaming buy it it's $10 y'all it's
like two it's like a combo meal just I
cuz that's what you know I really don't
like to ask for things and like I but I
feel like I have to get my bu merch yeah
my well I got to get the merch you know
merch a't ready but the merch ain't
ready yet y'all but like I would say you
know if you really support someone
because I feel like I know a lot of
people don't look at artists and
celebrities and they're like what do I
need to like you already got it or you
know what do you do for us like I'm one
day like I really want to do something
super big for like just people in
general yeah I love to give back I'm
always giving well this the thing is
like uh people who don't understand you
can still go to your Apple iTunes store
and buy an album MH very easily anytime
there's a friend of mine or an artist
that drops that I really want to
actually support I just buy it cuz then
you know you go on the Apple chart and
then and then if you uh you know if you
actually have physicals vinyl that's why
vinyl's so popping right now cuz people
like to support what they're watching
wait so with EP do EPS get vinyl yeah
you can do a vinl I thought that was
only like an album thing no you could do
a vinyl you could do a vinyl with
anything I have vinyls with my
misunderstood record but I mean that's
what I'm saying like you could do like a
limited run of vinyl like 500 they'll
sell out your fans will buy them they
day one they'll sell out but you know
them be taking a long time to like
months yeah like three or four months
but you put the pre-order up they'll
sell out and then you once you buy it I
just bought Andre 3000's flute album on
vinyl I got to go check that out I hear
a lot of people talking about it I want
to check it out listen it's the type of
music if you go to a Mage spot I would
love that and you're you know you got
someone massaging you it's it's on in
the background how many how many tracks
are on there listen it's a ridic it's
only eight songs but but it's an hour
and a half album oh each song's like 10
minutes if you're like at home and you
want to do some yoga you want to
meditate put on the three stacks Alum M
it's just flutes it's a lot of flute
[__] going on okay but I bought it on
vinyl cuz I'm I got Outcast right there
on V so I had to I had to support three
saacks support the people you love that
you say you love you have such a
hardcore like um honed in fan base that
like anytime you drop you got to make
sure you got you got to have the vinyl
you got to have the yeah but see Hood oh
that's why I didn't drop an album cuz I
feel like none of that okay so what
people don't understand is you can't
start getting vinyls ready or until
until everything's delivered to yeah
everything's delivered to all the dsps
they don't want to start any process
until everything's delivered so for me a
lot of things are last minute do you
have CDs like someone to a cop a CD I'll
tell y'all later on on my Snapchat I
don't I don't know I have to go check
but like you could do like so people
like to collect [__] like this now like
just like no one will ever like actually
put this tape in but you could do a
queen niga tape I don't know if I do I
don't think I have it for my but I
definitely have it for my my de album so
if y'all still want to that but yeah I
mean next time around we going to be we
going to be a lot more organized I just
I couldn't stand to wait longer to drop
music like people would have forgot
about me hey what's the uh podcast
called uh let's talk about it I like
that it I named it after a a a song that
I didn't put on my EP but I released a
song this earlier this um in January of
2023 and it's called let's talk about it
and so I thought it would be perfect to
name for a podcast thank you uh random
other question did you have you ever met
NBA young boy you guys have a song
together yeah I went to his house to do
the video in Utah yes what was that like
that was you know it was interesting it
was very he was well he was a gentleman
he was he was um I definitely judge a
book by I judge him by his Persona on
social media yeah which a lot of people
do yeah he was nice he was well like
softspoken um and you know he was just
uh being him you got to go to Utah I
went to Utah yep I had to do that
because I felt like I hadn't seen him in
a video with somebody else like in a
long time yeah all his videos have just
been like at his house yeah so I mean po
a portion of my video for no fake love
was that that was at that house it was a
house uhhuh did he try to convert you to
Mormonism uh what no cuz he I think he's
Mormon now oh yeah no he ain't do that
yeah shout to the Mormons out in Utah
they run that [__] out there oh yeah
yeah you know it was you know it was he
was I think uh think he was in mid
moving or something like that so very
interesting guy super he's an enigma I
feel like he's an enig he's dm' me
before like randomly he's a what an
enigma what is that he's like he's just
like a like a thing like he's like he's
just so like abstract as like a
personality like what like you know what
I mean like like he it's like he's very
unpredictable yeah he's he's just like
his own thing like he's NBA young boy
he's not a person he's like a he's just
like a he is a person though no no no
but like he's like more than a person no
no I know what you're saying like but I
think you know what it is I feel like
that's why he feels so misunderstood
fair enough cuz a lot of people do look
at him as a you know more than a person
and like he just want people to see him
as a person yeah so like yeah like he
just dm' me randomly I did a interview
with glor that he really liked and he
was just
like hey man do you really enjoy what
you do and I was like yeah he's like you
look like you have a lot of fun fun and
and uh it was like the most I looked at
my phone and it said DM from his and I
was like this guy what the [__] is this
right so I hit him I was like thanks man
like yeah you know and I was like hey
one day I'd like to have you on the show
and he just liked the message yeah yeah
but it was like so Random nice guy from
what I you know our our three message
change he he was super supportive of the
record he ain't charge me he didn't
charge you he didn't charge me wow for
anything he's charged a lot like I don't
know why he chose to not charge me I was
like are you sure like he must rock with
you he and you know one of the things
that he told me I don't understand it
but like when I was at his house he was
like he was like I need you more than
you need me and I'm like what like I'm I
really did not understand like that I'm
like what you mean like I need no I
think I think young boy like at the end
of the day like for whatever reason the
industry has kind of shunned him so I
think for him to do like a record with
someone like you who's like a big deal
singer like I feel like it it helps I I
feel like I feel like it's a a habitual
you know thing and I and I think I feel
like young boy is kind of like lowkey
like Tupac to a lot of people in this in
this generation like he's one of the
ones but for whatever reason a lot of
The Gatekeepers of hip-hop they don't
really rock with him and I think it's
it's you know it's like bro this guy is
like a generationally big rapper when it
comes to like numbers on the my son my
son loves the NBA young boys so there's
not a lot of rappers who have like
8-year-old kids having an NBA young like
like their like themed birthday part
I've seen so many NBA young boy themed
birthday parties that's crazy it is it
is crazy but it it is a thing that's
fine well I appreciate you pulling up
thank you go support the
EP episode two of her podcast by the
time you watch this it'll already be out
so go watch it thank you and we're
having Jay wa to on here fire yeah so
appreciate you pulling up thank you boom
yo we're wrapping up an interview man of
course we want to shout out to our
family at harden baby Harden Las Vegas
celebrating their seventh birthday this
month so happy birthday to harden uh
want to give a shout out to the whole
family over there when you're in Las
Vegas you got to pull up the Hardin tell
them that the bootleg head podcast sends
you they're going to take care of you it
is the craziest selection of Premium
cannabis in the country all Under One
Roof you walk in and it's just a Vibe
beautiful Bud tenders amazing smoke just
the illis merch you know what I'm saying
and it's right in Las Vegas right in s
City so you land in Vegas you about to
go gamble with your boys you get in that
cab you say take me to harden they're
going to know exactly where to take you
all right shout out to harden go follow
him Harden Las Vegas or go to the
website Hardin vegas.com